Musik
Musik Musik Musik Musik Musik Musik Musik Musik Musik Musik Ich habe schon wieder Kritik bekommen Von unserer Lieblingshörerin, die meinte, immer wenn sie unseren Podcast anhat, stürzt sie ihre Podcast-App ab.
Das ist genau die gleiche, die auch dieses Knäckebrot-Problem hatte, die sie hören konnte, weil sie selber zu laut war mit dem Knäckebrot.
Unsere Community kurz, mal in einem Satz.
Wie hat dir die Folge mit Nils Vogelberg gefallen?
Ja, der Ton war nicht gut.
Das habe ich dir im Vertrauen gesagt.
Guten Abend, meine Damen und Herren und herzlich willkommen zu Das Podcast UFO.
Während Florentin noch ein bisschen an seinem Mikrofon rumtechtelmächtelt. Grüße Sie schon mal. Hallo und herzlich willkommen zum Podcast UFO, mein Name ist Stefan Thietze und der, der so neun Chalon rumklatscht in der Gegend, das ist kein geringerer als unser beliebter, allseits fröhlicher Florentin Willen.en. Herzlich willkommen. Oh, heisst du, willkommen sehr geehrte Damen und Herren. Mein Name ist, ach, wir fangen nochmal an. Wir machen einfach mal drei Anfänge. Wir machen heute mal eine Sendung. Und dann kann sich der Hörer aussuchen, welcher denn der Beste ist. Genau, der Alternative ist Anfang. Steht ihr vor dem richtigen Anfang, seht ihr wenn? Ich würde sagen, wir machen alle fünf Minuten einen neuen Anfang einfach, um einfach immer diese Aufbruchsstimmung, weil, man muss ja... Wir haben auch unsere Musik ein bisschen zu featuren, weil ich finde immer so schade, dass die nur am Anfang kommt. Ja, das stimmt. Und die ist eigentlich das Beste am Podcast. Ja. Habe ich jetzt ein Konzept gebracht oder so? Okay, neuer Anfang, neuer Anfang und go. Aber Achtung, ich habe meinen Gag. Wie findest du den? Und zwar, ein Pärchen oder zwei Leute oder drei sitzen an einem Tisch. Und ein Afrikaner oder ein Afrikaner, ist egal. Der Papst sitzt an einem Tisch und die sehen so einen Kerzenständer im Restaurant, so ein Stück von ihrem Tisch entfernt. Und dann sagt der eine zu der anderen, das Date läuft schlecht und der Papst ist dabei, von daher sowieso ein bisschen awkward, sagt, ich habe noch nie gesehen,
wie eine Kerze ausgebrannt ist.
Also ich habe immer gesehen, dass eine Kerze
an ist und dass Kerzen halt irgendwann aus sind,
aber ich habe noch nie den Moment erlebt,
wo eine Kerze wirklich ausgeht.
Und die Kerze da hinten ist schon fast
am Ausgehen. Jetzt gucken wir mal
zu, wie die Kerze ausgeht.
Und dann gucken Frau und der Mann, die Frau denkt sich,
wow, das ist mit Abstand das beste Date, das ich je hatte, schauen diese Kerze anht. Und dann gucken Frau und der Mann, die Frau denkt sich, wow, das ist mit Abstand beste Date, das ich je
hatte, schauen diese Kerze an,
gucken ungefähr noch so drei Minuten zu
und dann die Kerze,
die Flamme wird immer
niedriger, fängt an zu flackern,
sie wird immer kleiner, die Flamme
geht aus und der Kerzen
Ständer fällt um.
Also das, was komplett Unerwartetes passiert. Ja, aber da hätte irgendwie der Kellner kommen müssen, der kurz davor irgendwie die Umkünfte oder so. Nein, das ist ja die erwartete Pointe, dass es ihm nicht ausgeht, wenn alle darauf warten, dass es ausgeht. Also so ein Zauberer erscheint und büht sich die postlich aus, oder so? Ja, oder halt irgendwie so, weil du hast diesen Spannungsmoment, es geht langsam runter und es geht aus und es explodiert oder so, oder es fällt um, oder irgendwie sowas in der Richtung. Ja, aber umfallen war da vielleicht ein bisschen zu wenig die Erwartung gebrochen. Weiß ich nicht. Oder es fällt sehr langsam um. Ja, sowas. Oder ein Minotaurus erscheint und pusselt die Ausrede. Aber einfach die Tatsache ist ja im Grunde die heisenbergsche Idee, ist ja heisenbergsche Statt. Die heisenbergsche Unschärfe-Relation. Die Tatsache, dass du etwas beobachtest, verändert das, was du beobachtest. Und das einfach mal zu übertragen auf eine reale Situation, dass ich habe noch nie gesehen, dass Punkt, Punkt, Punkt. Und wenn du es dann tatsächlich siehst, passiert was ganz Abgefahrenes, weil du gerade zuschaust. Verstehst du, was ich meine? Das ist Heisenberg. Ich habe mich noch nie mit einer Frau gesehen, wenn ich mich dabei beobachte. Punkt, war nur ein Statement. Hast du eigentlich noch diese Frau auf deinen Spiegel gemalt, die dir so einen Arm um die Schulter legt, wenn du vor dem Spiegel stehst? Ist das eigentlich noch so? Ja, habe ich noch so. Es ist so. Aber läuft nicht mehr so gut gerade, oder? Läuft nicht mehr so gut die Bezirn. Nee, ich weiß nicht, was du gesagt hast. Du! Ich weiß nicht, was ich da auch so lange sage. Was du gesagt hast, was du gesagt hast. Was letzte Woche zu Nils Buckelberg gesagt hast, dass man dem quasi nicht, dass man einem Gast nicht die Möglichkeit geben soll, dass man verlieren kann, aber nicht muss. Und wir haben genau das gemacht. Ich habe genau das mehrmals gemacht, in dem ich gesagt habe, Nils Bokelberg, jetzt sag doch mal die Mailbox-Ansage. Genau das habe ich gemacht. Du hast beendet und genau danach das gemacht, was du eigentlich anders hast. Aber das machen wir zum Beispiel im normalen Gespräch. Wir machen das eigentlich kontinuierlich so, dass wir uns gegenseitig in die Pfanne hauen wollen. Ja gut, aber wir sind ja Sparringspartner. Wir müssen uns ja gegenseitig zu Höchstleistungen ausfordern. Ganz kurz, die letzte Folge. Ich habe es mir tatsächlich angehört mit Nils Bokeberg. Ich habe ein bisschen arg viel geredet, ist mir selber aufgefallen, es kamen auch kritische Kommentare. Es tut mir leid, ich war in der Folge ein bisschen aufgedreht, ein bisschen nervös irgendwie. Ich glaube, es liegt auch daran, dass ich generell anderen Leuten nicht genug vertraue, dass ich immer denke, ich muss die Situation in die eigene Hand nehmen, weil ich mir denke, sobald jemand anderes als ich redet, ist die Gefahr, dass es nicht so geil wird. Und bei mir weiß ich, dass es mittelmässig ist. Nein, aber wir versuchen ja auch den tatsächlichen Beweggründen nachzuforschen hier in diesem Podcast. Wenn das, was du gerade sagst, irgendwie eine Stunde lang geht, die eine Stunde lang entschuldigt, dass du so viel redest und dann der Podcast so weicht. Und dass ich zu schnell unterbreche. Ja, das ist auch eine erwartbare Pointe, dass man jemanden mit der Entschuld sich zu unterbrechen, unterbricht. Aber wir kommen näher. Wir kommen dem Gag immer näher. Wir nähern uns dem besten Gag aller Zeiten. Ja, ich habe mir ein paar Gags aufgeschrieben. Nee, ich wollte mir kurz... Wir hätten vielleicht... Ich bin heute für eine Top 5 mal wieder. Und es war für die Top 5 der Dinge, die wir in Nitzburg-Gerberg hätten fragen sollen, aber es aber nicht getan haben. Ja. Ja, finde ich gut. Hau rein. Ja, machen wir aber nicht, oder? Nur die Idee ist lustig, dass man das macht. Die Top 5 der verworfenen Top 5 Ideen. Ich glaube, bei Top 5 gibt es auch keine Möglichkeit mehr, das Format zu brechen und andere Top 5 zu machen, als die, die man erwartet, weil schon alles gemacht wurde. Aber lass uns mal kurz der Sache auf den Grund gehen, warum das letzte Woche dann irgendwie hinten raus so ein bisschen schwierig geworden ist. Ich glaube, dass Booster mal wieder ein grosses Problem war. Leider, unser Hauptspons dafür beantwortlich. Ich habe es noch nie erlebt. Ich war abends, ich habe hier noch aufgeräumt, weil du eher los musstest, bin nach Hause gegangen und war so nervös. Ich habe von zwei Dosen Booster, ich war so nervös, ich bin so durch die Wohnung gerannt und habe irgendwie angefangen, so Fenster anzufassen und so Bilder gerade zu hängen. Ist die Scheibe noch da? Ist sie noch da? Jetzt ist es Bildingeschief. Jetzt ist bin ich die ganze Zeit so rumgelaufen, ohne Sinn, habe Leute angerufen und habe so ganz komische, wirre Sachen gemacht. Und das war einfach nicht gesund, das habe ich noch nie erlebt, so was. Ich musste einfach dann völlig kaputt in der Biene. Ich wollte die Roofies eigentlich in Nils-Pose tun, deswegen hat nicht so ganz geklappt. Tatsächlich. Sehr guter Gag. Ich war gestern auf einer Party und ich hatte das Gefühl, dass mir jemand Roofies in den Drink getan hat. Und ich hatte mich gerade mit einer Frau unterhalten und ich habe gesagt, hey, wenn du mit mir schlafen willst, sag mir das einfach. Es ist kein Grund da, mich unter Drogen zu setzen. Wir können das auch einfacher regeln. Ich fand es nicht so lustig tatsächlich. Aber naja, gut. Du hast gestern eine sehr Menge hilarious Dinge gemacht. Ja, ja, ja. Ich habe jetzt richtig viel rausgebracht Möchtest du davon eigentlich erzählen, oder wollen wir das heute komplett anrechterlegen? Nee, nee, nee, nee. Aber bei Zeiten hauen wir es raus, so ein bisschen wie die Joy-Story. Wir teasern immer darauf hin. Ich finde auch geil, dass du immer so geile Sachen erlebst und ich immer darauf hin teaser. Also schaut mal selber, wenn ich diese ganze Zeit auf Dinge teaser, die andere gemacht haben, einfach selber rausgehen würde. Ja, aber das ist zum Beispiel eine Frage, wir haben bald wieder einen tollen Gast und ich bereite mir jetzt ein paar Fragen vor. Du brauchst da nicht irgendwie geheimnisvoll tun. Jeder hat mitbekommen, wer das ist. Ja, okay, gut, das stimmt. Aber wir machen bald trotzdem geheimnisvoll. Aber da... Auch wieder so ein Ding. Ich tiere, was du eigentlich erreicht hast. Da habe ich mir auch überlegt, inwiefern es wichtig ist, um lustig zu sein und auch, sage ich mal, gerade ein guter Stand-up-Community zu sein, ob es wichtig ist, ein interessantes Leben zu führen, ob es wichtig ist, dass man viele Dinge erlebt und viele Dinge einen großen Erfahrungsschatz aufbaut, um daraus ziehen zu können. Es gibt natürlich unterschiedliche Arten von Comedy, es gibt auch die, die einfach Gags machen, einfach Witze, die ohne jetzt irgendeinen persönlichen Rahmen auskommen. Also Damage Martin-mäßig. Genau. Ja, und die das vielleicht nicht unbedingt brauchen, aber dann die Leute wie Louis C.K., die zum Beispiel was ihm im eigenen Leben erzählen, die das dann eher brauchen. Hast du das Gefühl, du performst besser, wenn du ein spannendes, erfülltes Leben führst? Ja, ich überlege auch immer die ganze Zeit, ob man vielleicht einfach leben sollte. So bis 30 sollte man einfach zur Schule gehen, studieren, Erfahrungen sammeln, Weltreise machen, fast sterben, fast irgendwie Paragliding machen,
so ganz viele Dinge am Rand zur Selbstzerstörung,
um dann ab 30
einfach einen Schlussstrich zu ziehen,
in so ein Apartment zu ziehen
und dann einfach zu schreiben.
Und dann einfach so einen Schlussstrich
zieht, einfach so das Leben zweiteilen.
Aber wenn du mit 30 anfängst zu schreiben, bist du halt nicht gut.
Ja, das ist interessant.
Da bist du halt dann nicht mehr gut.
Louis C. Kay hat auch mal gesagt, man muss einfach studieren. Das reicht ja schon, und Kinder haben. Er hat sich die Frage, was die Frage, was die Frage, was die Frage, was die Frage, was die Frage, was die Frage, was die Frage, was die Frage, was die Frage, was die Frage, was die Frage, was die Frage, was die Frage, was die Frage, was die Frage, was die Frage, was die Frage, was die Frage, was die Frage, was die Frage, was die Frage, was die Frage, was die Frage, was die Frage, was die Frage, was die Frage, was die Frage, was die Frage, was die Frage, was die Frage, was die Frage, was die Frage, was die Frage, was die Frage, was die Frage, was die Frage, was die Frage, was die Frage, was die Frage, was die Frage, was die Frage, was die Frage, was die Frage, was die Frage, was die Frage, was die Frage, was die Frage, was die Frage, was die Frage, was die Frage, was die Frage, was die Frage, was die Frage, was die Frage, was die Frage, was die Frage, was die Frage, was die Frage, was die Frage, was die Frage, was die Frage, was die Frage, was die Frage, was die Frage, was die Frage, was die Frage, was die Frage, was die Frage, was die Frage, was die Frage, was die Frage, was die Frage, was die Frage, was die Frage, was die Frage, was die Frage, was die Frage, was die Frage, was die Frage, was die Frage, was die Frage, was die Frage, was die Frage, was die Frage, was die Frage, was die Frage, was die Frage, was die Frage, was die Frage, was die Frage, was die Frage, was die Frage, was die Frage, was die Frage, was die Frage, was die Frage, was die Frage, was die Frage, was die Frage, was die Frage, was die Frage, was die Frage, was die Frage, was die Frage, was die Frage, was die Frage, was die Frage, bist du halt nicht gut. Ja, das ist interessant. Da bist du halt nicht mehr gut. Louis C. K. hat auch mal gesagt, man muss einfach studieren. Das reicht ja schon. Und Kinder haben. Er meinte auch irgendwann, dass er nicht hat, worüber er reden kann mehr, weil er kein Leben hatte in dem Sinne. Er hat sich sehr lange darüber geärgert, dass er kein Leben hatte. Und er hat irgendwann gesagt, dass das Seil aus dieser Kluft, aus dieser Schlucht des Lebens waren seine Kinder. Du wirst immer besser darin, Louis C. C. zu übersetzen, merke ich gerade. Ja, ich weiß, ich übe daran seit zwölf Jahren. Aber er, das ist seine Kinder dann halt und er will, aus denen quasi, er zwingt die quasi dazu, Dinge zu erleben. Lustig zu sein, ja. Er weckt die auch manchmal früher auf, einfach damit sie irgendwie... Und Dinge zu erleben, von denen er dann erzählen kann. Und das ist so ein bisschen, was ich mit dir die ganze Zeit mache. Ich zwinge mich dazu, Dinge zu erleben und erzähle dann von denen vor dir im Podcast. Aber betrachtest du dein Leben nicht manchmal auch so wie so ein Projekt, dass du sagst jetzt zum Beispiel, ich muss mehr mit Leuten irgendwie, ich muss rausgehen und Leute kennenlernen, einfach weil ich das üben will und weil ich das gut können können. Ja, auch da möchte ich gerne mit deinem Satz antworten. Aber das ist ja im Prinzip so, man sieht, also du sagst ja zum Beispiel, dass man das Leben wie eine Sitcom leben sollte. Ist das so? Nur weil ich das auf dem Arm tätowiert habe, ist das nicht meine Meinung. Ja, ein bisschen so, als würdest du dich selber interviewen, oder? Das ist das lahmste Zitat aller Zeiten. Kannst du nicht ein cooleres Zitat machen? Ich habe heute überlegt, wo ich auch nicht weiß, ich habe heute mal überlegt, wäre es nicht so, wenn Kant hinter jedes seiner Zitate einfach ein Alter setzen würde, aber dann nicht viel mehr Anerkennung heutzutage? Oder einen Reim einfach einbaut. Oder so eine dramatische Pause. Aber benutzt seine Vernunft, Alter, ist einfach viel tiefgründiger für dich.
Die Würde des Menschen ist, wait for it, unantastbar.
Ja, genau. So würde das Grundgesetz auch viel mehr Spaß machen, glaube ich.
Das Grundgesetz der Art, wo kommen die am wenigsten stattfindet.
Das Grundgesetz in Jugendsprache. Ja, ja.
Was habe ich damit gemeint, mit das Leben bis an das Sitcom?
Ja, einfach, dass man, so habe ich es interpretiert und so lebe ich es, dass man einfach auch manchmal so die Awkwardness suchen muss, einfach mal rausgehen und Leute konfrontieren muss. Heute dachte ich mir auch zum Beispiel, ich laufe mich mal durch die U-Bahn und zum Job und so, indem ich Kopfhörer im Ohr habe. Aber im Prinzip ist das ja falsch. Eigentlich sollte man auch in der Fähigkeit an, dass man einfach die Menschen konfrontieren sollte, indem man die Kopfhörer
rausnimmt und zuhört, was Leute
bereden und so, neben dir in der U-Bahn und so.
Und das beobachten, du bist ja der Observator,
du bist so ein Typ, der einfach rumläuft
und Leute beobachtet eigentlich. Aber auf der anderen Seite,
ich denke es dir manchmal, zum Beispiel, wenn ich mir denke,
okay, besonders kleine Kinder, die zwölf Jahre alt sind,
beobachte ich sehr gerne. Mit der Nacktscanner-App
in der Hand hier. Ich mir überlege,
ich werde irgendwann eingeladen und habe nicht so richtig Bock, Leute zu treffen und höre dann stattdessen, gehe ich spazieren und höre irgendwie einen Podcast, wo ich denke, okay, du bist jetzt total antisocial und du hast keine coolen Erlebnisse. Auf der anderen Seite denke ich mir, warum soll ich irgendwie Günter Grassler mit Armen verbringen, der mir irgendwie erzählt, warum es in seinem langweiligen Beruf nicht vorangeht. Und ich könnte genauso gut einen Podcast hören, wo mir ein fucking Mark Maron oder ein Joe Rogan oder fucking krasse Leute
oder ein Louis C.K. einfach
erzählen, die einfach viel bessere Unterhalter sind.
Wo ich mir denke, kann man sich da nicht diese
Arroganz leisten und sagen, wenn ich die Wahl habe,
zwischen dem Interview von
Ben Schwartz und Louis C.K. oder irgendwie
Gertrude, die mir erzählt, warum sie
findet, dass vegan jetzt doch eine gute
Idee ist. Ja, aber du lernst
dann aber halt nicht selber zu sprechen, glaube ich.
Du lernst nicht, Unterhalter zu werden, wenn du
Unterhaltern zuhörst. Also ich glaube, du lernst
Vielen Dank. dass Vegan jetzt doch eine gute Idee ist. Ja, aber du lernst dann aber halt nicht selber zu sprechen, glaube ich. Du lernst nicht, Unterhalter zu werden, wenn du Unterhaltern zuhörst. Also ich glaube, du lernst eher, wenn du sehr oft mit langweiligen Menschen redest und versuchst, irgendwann bist du so weit, dass du selbst daraus eine unterhaltsame Situation kreieren kannst, glaube ich, kannst du ebenfalls auch gut unterhalten. Aber auf der anderen Seite, wenn du Unterhaltern, ich mache heute genau, was du jetzt so vorgebracht hast. Du lest dich nicht aufhalten, ne? Und was du... Das Mikrofon ist aus, ne? Ich hab dich ja schon den Spur gelöscht, ne? An dem bei Rätselgrüder will. Ne, ist egal, ich weiß nicht, was ich sagen wollte. Ja. Ne, denkst du dir auch manchmal, dass wenn du in einem Gespräch mit normalen Leuten, in Anführungszeichen, bist und die Gags machen, dass man dann so ein bisschen denkt, so ja, da bin ich eigentlich schon... War Gertrude der Name, der normalste Name, der dir eben eingefallen ist? Ja. Was wolltest du eben sagen? Merkst du nicht, dass man über so diesen freundschaftlichen, kollegialen Humor mal irgendwie einfach schon drüber hinaus ist, wo man sich denkt, so ja, das habe ich schon durchgespielt irgendwie, wenn dann Leute irgendwie so lame Gags machen, weil ich finde, das ist eine andere Art von Humor, so dieser soziale, freundschaftliche Humor, wo man dann sagt, irgendwie, wenn dann irgendjemand was Zweideutiges sagt und man dann sagt so, oh ja, typisch Stefan,wie keine Ahnung, wenn du sagst, ja, ich habe gestern eine Kerze ausgeblasen. Typisch Stefan, der denkt immer nur ans Blasen und die Gründe lacht und der denkt, hey Leute, hey, Entschuldigung, ihr lacht jetzt zwar gerade, aber der Gag war nicht gut. Also vielleicht ist das euch gerade nicht aufgefallen. Aber wo man sich einfach denkt, das ist vielleicht auch eine andere Art von Humor, weil wir sehen nur den Gag und die Technik des Gags und denken, der Gag war nicht gut, wohingegen die anderen natürlich einen Moment der Verbrüderung sehen,
einen Moment der Zwischenmenschlichkeit sehen und anders lachen als wir
und einfach auf einem anderen Niveau lachen als wir.
Das ist nicht nötigerweise unter oder über uns, sondern was ganz anderes irgendwie ist.
Ja, aber auch wenn du jetzt mit Leuten rausgehen müsstest oder zu Leuten gehen müsstest,
mit denen du dich Ärzte nicht so gut verstehst oder einfach mit denen du dich nicht so gut identifizieren kannst,
dann ist natürlich auch die Frage, sind das dann die Leute, die du später auch unterhalten musst? Und musst du quasi diese Situation mit diesen Leuten suchen, um das zu lernen? Oder sind Leute, die später dann zu deinem Senderprogramm kommen, eh andere? Aber die Frage ist die, lernt der Löwe das Jagen von der Gazelle oder von anderen Löwen? Wir lassen hier fünf Minuten mal kurz Ruhe. Wir spielen jetzt noch mal das Intro in der G-Dur-Variante. Wir spielen jetzt noch mal das Intro in der Rokoko-Variante und lassen Sie darüber nachdenken. Viel Spaß. Viel Spaß, hab jetzt die ersten Anrober. Ne, ich hab ja jetzt auch Bock, langsam Stand-Up zu machen. Also wir beide haben ja auch grosse Ambitionen in der Richtung. Und ich kann ja schon mal vorweggreifen, wir werden bald einen waschechten Stand-Up-Comedian als Gast haben, dem wir natürlich alle unsere Fragen stellen, weil ich glaube, wir konsumieren ja beide Stand-Up schon relativ lange, eigentlich seit wir uns für Comedy interessieren. Ich hab heute angefangen, tatsächlich. Es ist ja schon so ein bisschen die Königsdisziplin irgendwie. Und dann hat man so das natürliche Bedürfnis, das auch mal zu machen. Aber es ist halt schon auch irgendwie aus gutem Grund die Königsdisziplin, weil es halt knallhart ist. Ja, vor allem ist es auch so, man wächst ja in Deutschland damit auf, dass es was sehr Kommerzielles ist. Es wird dafür mit Geld gemacht, man sieht es im TV. Die Stadien sind gefüllt. Die Stadien sind gefüllt und wenn man aber jetzt so ein bisschen älter wird, anfängt, Englisch zu sprechen und anfängt, über den Tellerrand hinauszugucken, standarmäßig, dann fällt einem ja auf, dass es was ganz anderes ist. Und das habe ich jetzt bis heute gebraucht, das zu verstehen und in Worte zu fassen und mir anzugucken. Aber ich habe, wie gesagt, ich bereite mich jetzt nur noch darauf vor, mit dem Gedanken, mal was zu schreiben, so langsam. Dann habe ich bei Google eingegeben, was Tipps sind, wenn man zum ersten Mal ein Stand-Up-Programm schreibt. Dann habe ich einen Menschen gefunden. Luke Mockridge. Dann habe ich Luke Mockridge gefunden. Und er hat gesagt, so ein Stand-Up-Coach, wo auch du eben im Vorgespräch die berechtigte Frage gestellt hast, wo sind denn diese Stand-Up-Schulen eigentlich? Wo sind diese ganzen Stand- glaube, man muss da einfach irgendwann einen Brief bekommen, im Alter von elf Jahren, und wieder den abholt zur Stand-up-Akademie. Ja, aber das ist doch so ein Wort, das man dann bei Google Maps eingibt und dann so ganz ultra viele rote Punkte sich bilden. Die ganze Landkarte ist voll. Ja, ja, genau. So die ehemalige Sowjetunion, so alles voll, so die Grenze ist abgezeichnet. Viel mehr Stand-up-Schulen als normale Schulen. So auch Afrika, die Stand-up-Schulen-Dichte ist unfassbar groß. Aber wo sind die? Aber ich finde die im normalen Leben nicht. Es ist vielleicht so, ich kann Stand-up-Schulen sehen. Ich glaube, es gibt viele Schulen für Dinge, von denen man normalerweise denkt, das kann einem niemand beibringen. Hundeschulen. Man lernt einen Hund zu finden. Das stimmt, Baumschule, ja. Ja, der war nicht so gut. Eigentlich, nein, weil du immer schon den besten Gag vorwegnimmst. Du musst eigentlich einen mittleren machen, damit ich nochmal einen draufsetzen kann, damit du nochmal einen draufsetzen kannst. Das sind halt so Regeln, die man lernen kann. Das war in der letzten Folge auch sehr gut, wo wir immer noch einen Gag machen wollten, aber irgendwann wurde er aber noch inhaltsleer und wo ich dann auch Sachen rausschneiden musste, was aber nicht, wenn er mal genau hinl mal genau hinter der letzten Folge, man hört, wie ich versucht habe, Dinge rauszuschneiden, aber es ging halt nicht, weil wir halt in einem Raum waren, alle anderen Mikros haben halt aufgefangen, was man selber sagt oder was Florian sagt. Man hört es im Hintergrund so ganz weird, wie jemand reinruft. und so. Genau, als wäre es noch eine andere Person im Raum, irgendwie so der Praktikante hinter der Scheibe und so
und wenn da
genau, das ist der unlussigste Typ der Welt,
den wir hören. Als wäre es noch eine andere Person im Raum, irgendwie so der Praktikant, der hinter der Scheibe noch so blablabla.
Genau, und das ist der unlustigste Typ der Welt,
den, den erhört. Das war nicht wir,
aber der unlustigste Typ der Welt.
Der sich immer angesprochen fühlt, aber einfach
im anderen Raum sitzt und immer mitredet.
Das klingt, dass man da rein ruft.
Wir müssen uns die Aufnahme abbrechen, der Depp da drüben
denkt, wir reden mit ihm.
Ja, dann habe ich halt die Seite gefunden,
wo drei Tipps sind, drei große Tipps. Der erste Tipp war, sei lustig. Aha, no shit. Okay. Das ist immer so grossartig. Fünf Tipps zum Daten, sei selbstbewusst. Alles klar, okay, und los geht's. Alles klar, und jetzt geht's raus. Jetzt zweite Tipp war dann Respektiere das Handwerk. Respektiere die Pflege. Ich habe das, den ersten habe ich noch verstanden, beim zweiten muss ich ein bisschen länger nachdenken. Und der dritte war dann, und das war sehr gut, der dritte Tipp war sehr hilfreich für jemanden wie mich, das war eine Pointe. Der dritte Tipp müsste eigentlich die Pointe gewesen sein. Das ist eine Pointe. Das ist sehr hilfreich für jemanden wie mich, der es zum ersten Mal macht, war, starte niemals mit neuem Material. Moment mal, ich wollte das zum ersten Mal, womit soll ich denn dann anfangen? Und seitdem hat sich ich vom leeren Blatt und weiß nicht, ich glaube, es wird nie mehr. Aber ich finde generell, solche Tipps für solche kreativen Sachen sind entweder immer viel zu allgemein, wie sei du selbst, oder viel zu konkret, wie, ja klar, es kann immer ein bisschen schwierig sein, wenn man fünf Minuten hat, nach jemandem, der schon mehr Erfahrung hat, wenn irgendwie schon drei Acts vor dir kamen, und du danach, das ist kurz vor der Mittagspause, wie macht man es dann irgendwie genau da nochmal die Aufmerksamkeit des Publikums zu kriegen? Ich brauche erstmal einen Stift, okay, ich fange gerade an. Wo kriege ich Papier her? Er hat auch heute jemand gesagt, von dem Sender-Programm, den ich heute geguckt habe im Laufe des Tages, da hat jemand gesagt, Dinge werden auch relativ sehr anders, wenn man plötzlich sehr generell wird oder sehr spezifisch wird. Zum Beispiel man kann sagen, ich liebe Kinder, ist okay, aber man sagt, ich liebe Zwölfjährige, wird sehr schnell, sehr awkward. Das ist aber genauso mit diesen Listen, wo jemand plötzlich sehr spezifisch wird und man denkt, fuck you, oder halt be funny, ja was, oder du musst halt die Mitte finden. Aber diese drei Tipps waren nicht so hilfreich jetzt. Ja, falls ihr Tipps habt, wie Stefan Tittler auf seinem, hast du dir einen Künstlernamen überlegt eigentlich? Ich habe irgendwann mal überlegt, da war ich noch sehr klein, da habe ich mir überlegt, Tizio mich zu nennen, das heisst Typ auf Italienisch, also so Typ. Ja, guck mal, ohne Scheiss, Louis Zikey hat irgendwann gedacht, ich habe einen seltsamen Nachnamen, ich weiß gar nicht, wie heißt er eigentlich? Oh, gute Frage. Kevin Klein. Sagt er, er könnte googeln in der Zeit, aber er hat sich lieber einen guten Gang ausgedacht. Er hat sich lieber einen schlechten Gang ausgedacht. Ja, ich drehe das manchmal in meinem Kopf um, was Comedy macht. Nee, und der hat sich halt C. K. gedacht, was auch eigentlich relativ uncool ist, aber irgendwann hat sich halt so eingebürgert. dann... Nein, aber ich küsse, sein Name ist, finde ich, lame. So, das hat das Problem mit diesen ganzen YouTubern, wenn man mit dem mal privat spricht, man weiss nie, soll man die jetzt mit ihrem YouTube-Namen ansprechen oder nicht, oder also, ich würde generell normalen Namen sprechen, aber den kennt man dann oft nicht, da muss man raten, dann sagt man Moritz, dann weiss man nicht, wer angeschön. Ja, oder ist es sehr creepy, wenn man plötzlich, wenn man nur jemanden als seinen Künstlernamen kennt und du sprichst plötzlich mit seinem richtigen Namen. Ja, ja, wenn du zu Superman gehst und sagst, hey Clark, sorry, sorry. Hey Bruce, oh, ich meine Batman. Der dumme Bruder, irgendwie Superman, ja. Superman. Superman. Ja, auf Grundlage unseres Gotto-Scan, dachte ich. Ich habe schon mal überlegt, ob ich dann, wenn ich beim Stand-Up mal mache, einfach auf die Bühne gehe und einfach so zehn Minuten lang so ein Louis-DK-Video abspiele. Einfach, weil ich mir denke, ich werde es nicht besser machen als er und ich bringe euch lieber jetzt zehn gute Minuten und stehe dann da mit so einem kleinen iPhone in der Hand und dann einfach so ein YouTube-Video. Er zeigt den Leuten einfach so ein
YouTube-Video, was lustig ist,
wo ich denke, da habt ihr jetzt vielleicht mehr davon,
als mich zu hören, wie ich versage.
Vor allem, ich glaube, dein Standard wird im Endeffekt so eine
komplette Metakritik
sein. Du versuchst, das Medium zu brechen,
du versuchst irgendwie alle Konformitäten,
irgendwie, du stehst mit dem Rücken
zum Publikum, du machst nur ironische Gags,
das, was man am Ende machen soll, machst du am Anfang und du machst alles anders, wo du denkst, ich revolutioniere das Medium und es wird niemand verstehen. Genau, niemand wird lachen und in 50 Jahren, wenn ich tot bin, dann wird es irgendwie wiedergefunden werden und so gehypt werden. Ja genau, und dann bist du eigentlich der Mitbegründer einer neuen Strömung, den Tiziosen. Tizismus. Bist du eigentlich ein Stalaktitz oder ein Stalakmit? Das kommt hin und vor, den ich... Manchmal muss... Aber das ist Versagen! Das ist Versagen, was die große Sache ist. Aber ihr könnt trotzdem... Ich habe gerade Kontaktlinsen drin und immer wenn ich lache, sehe ich alle sehr verschwommen. Was mich die ganze Zeit dazu bringt, einfach nicht zu lachen. Ich will einfach nicht lachen. Einfach auch körperlich der schlechteste Seiner-Publikum sein. Dein Körper rebelliert gegen den Humor einfach. Wundersteckt nur das schlechteste Seiner-Publikum. Ich will einfach nicht lachen, es tut mir leid, aber ich habe eine gute Begründung. Ich sehe sonst ganz verschwommen. Macht trotzdem bitte ein Bild von so einer Tropfsteinhöhle, wo statt einem Stalaktiten ein Kopf von Stefan Titzel ist. Es würde mich sehr freuen, einfach um einfach diesen sehr schlechten Gag. Und dann erklärt es eurer Mutter, machen wir ein T-Shirt, genau, machen wir ein T-Shirt, Stalaktitze, ja, warum nicht? Einfach mal einfach seinen Scheitern vor sich her schieben. Im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes. Ich glaube, für sowas wurde auch Photoshop programmiert. Also mit dem Wissen, dass sowas so benutzt wird. Vor allem dafür müsste eigentlich Paint benutzt werden. Es müsste doch irgendwie eine klarere Grenze gezogen werden, ob man Photoshop benutzen darf. Es sollte so ein Photoshop-Führerschein gemacht werden. Habt ihr auch damals Rollbrett-Führerscheine gemacht? Also haben wir eben schon... Nee, tatsächlich, ich dachte, das wäre ein Gag. Nee, wir haben wirklich einen Rollbrett-Führerschein gemacht. Wir passieren sehr viele lustige Dinge, die... Aber was ist denn ein Rollbrett? Du meinst ein Skateboard oder was? Nein, ein Rollbrett. Was ist denn ein Rollbrett? Ein Brett und da sind dann vier Rollen drunter, die so ganz schlecht befestigt wurden. Warum benutzt man das? Anscheinend, da dachte man, das wird sich durchsetzen. Und wir haben dann damals im Sportunterricht wirklich wochenlang auf diesem Rollbrett rumgerollt, wo man sich mit dem Bauch drauflegt. Und das habe ich von ein paar Leuten auch gehört, die auf anderen Schulen waren, die haben das auch gehabt. Und ich dachte mir, es wäre in Deutschland so verbreitet irgendwie. Das ist so ein ganz öffentliches, offizielles Dokument, das man bekommt, in der Unterschrift vom Premierminister, irgendwie ein Rollbrettführerschein. Der Bürgerbeister von Carmen hat damals dann unterschrieben. So, zweite Aufgabe, Ich will, dass ihr ein Bild macht, ein Rollbrett, wo Stefan Titzel auf dem Bauch draufliegt und das als ganz offizielles Dokument gestaltet. Ihr kriegt heute ordentlich Hausaufgaben auf. Bereit euch mal drauf vor. Ne, wir werden den Stand-Up Zug weiter verfolgen. Hier könnt ihr jetzt tatsächlich Zeuge gewesen sein, wie Stefan Teitzler den ersten Schritt in die richtige Richtung getan hat.
Und in 20 Jahren, wenn er mal die Lanxess-Arena füllt, könnt ihr sagen, ich war dabei, als Stefan Timbel das erste Mal tatsächlich das Mikrofon in der Hand hatte und gesagt hat, ich mach das. Ey, würdest du jemals die Lanxess-Arena füllen wollen? Würdest du? Ach, ich glaube, das ist immer so eine Frage, weil ich glaube, der Mensch hat ja natürlich eine absolute unstillbare Gier innerhalb. Das ist wie, wenn ich jetzt sage, willst du eine Million Euro? Dann sage ich ja, aber sobald ich die habe, will ich noch mehr. Und ich glaube, so mit der Langsess-Aren ist dasselbe. Du denkst dir immer, nee, das will ich gar nicht, weil da geht die eigentliche Kunst verloren, blibla blub. Aber wenn du halt in der Branche schon zehn Jahre bist und alles erreicht hast und dann denkst du dir, okay, jetzt der nächste Schritt irgendwie
das Stadion füllen und dann mal irgendwie der nächste Schritt
mit dem Heissluftballon irgendwie und die Leute stehen
alle im Vorgarten und hören mir zu oder halt
irgendwie sowas in der Ecke, dass man das halt
immer extremer macht oder sich ja irgendwie
lebendig begraben Comedy macht oder
halt irgendwie sowas, wo es dann halt einfach weitergeht
und immer weiter. Ich glaube, man hat ja einfach diesen
Forscherdrang, man will immer weitergehen.
Also im Heissluftballon hat mich gerade beeindruckt. Ja. Die erste Comedy-Show auf dem Heissluftballon. Machen wir mal einen Podcast auf dem Heissluftballon? Vor drei Leuten. Es ist sau teuer. Wie viel kostet das denn? Ich glaube, es ist sau teuer. 350 Euro. Also, die Spendenbuttons sind immer noch aktiv, Leute. Wir versuchen den ersten Podcast. Ich habe die auch übrigens fleißig wieder auf Der erste Stand-Up-Auftritt von Stefan Titzler, vielleicht sogar auf dem Humorkongress Basel. Ihr könnt dabei sein. Ich habe das beste Publikum, wo man total gut mit Tinder-Gags und so kommt, man kann sehr gut mit Vorhaben. Ihr könnt dabei sein, wenn Stefan Titzel das erste Mal auf der Bühne steht. In Basel, Ende September, ihr könnt euch noch anmelden, wir sind dabei, wir machen da auch das erste Hörertreffen. Ich wollte uns da anmelden und dann war da so eine ganz fiese Tabelle, so eine ganz fiese Tabelle, wo die dann geschrieben haben, ja, wenn man sich bis zum 25. August anmeldet, kostet das so und so viel, wenn man bis September wartet, kostet das so und so viel, und es wurde immer rapide teurer. Und irgendwann bezahlt man so unfassbar viel Geld. Man soll damit sagen, dass du die Spenden unserer Hörer, die treu um jeden Erfolger, sag ich, dass du einfach faul bist. Ich glaube, nie hat sich jemand in so kurzer Zeit so unbeliebt gemacht, wie Stefan Titzel gerade eben, der zugegeben hat, dass seine Faulheit dafür verantwortlich ist, dass wir eure Spenden verbrennen im Endeffekt.
Ich bin der schlechteste Spendenverbrenner, auch weil ich öffentlich zugebe. Einfach so dann im Nebensatz. Das stimmt, aber das ist wirklich so, deswegen müssen wir eigentlich mal aufpassen.
Da sollten wir da einfach mal relativ schnell reagieren. Wir wurden in diesem Moment geflattert.
Bock auf eine Anekdote?
Ja, hau raus.
Die Podcast-Ufo, die Das-Podcast-Ufo, Anekdote.
Ich war letztens einkaufen und ich gehe immer ganz gerne einkaufen in Berlin im Kaufhof am Alexanderplatz, weil da gibt es eine riesengroße... Moment, du erinnerst immer wieder, wo du deine Lieblings-Einkaufsstelle. Einmal ist es Hit, einmal ist es nochmal.
Verschiedene Tage, verschiedene Einkaufszentren. Und manchmal habe ich einfach Lust auf Exotik, auf eine riesige Auswahl, auf Dinge aus Fernost. Kaufhof, auf eine riesen Auswahl an Koffern, Parfum und Spiegeln. Ich habe mich schon so oft mit dem Spiegelkabinett verlaufen, einfach weil ich wusste, wo ich bin. Ich lag auch schon ein paar Mal da im Bett und dachte mir einfach, schönes Bett, wenn die Pointe ausbleibt. Ein Roman in drei Akten. Und da gehe ich immer durch Lebensmittelabteilung und gucke, was es so alles gibt. Und da gibt es auch manchmal so diese Früchte, wo dann mal so saisonale Angebote sind.
Und da gab es so eine Frucht.
Und zwar war das eine Mischung aus Birne und Melone.
Das ist der Stefan Go Skins.
Er hat gerade den Popschutz entfernt.
It's getting real.
Shit's getting real.
Wenn du das Regelbuch so rufst.
Es ist im Mülleimer.
Ich rede ohne Popsutz ins Mikro.
Fuck you, Bild.
Nimm das, Gesellschaft.
Sehr gut.
Und da gab es so Frucht, das ist eine Mischung aus Melone und Birne.
Birne?
Eine Belone.
Und da hat er auch diese lustige Form der Birne beibehalten? Ja, ja. Nee, es war ganz komisch. Das Beste aus der Birne, nur das Schlechteste aus der Melone. Und ich dachte mir, ich hasse Melonen und liebe Birnen, das wird ein mittelmäßiges Erlebnis, auf das ich Bock habe. Und deswegen habe ich mir da welche geholt, ich habe mir ein paar andere Sachen gekauft. Und da stand dann auch so ein Zettel dabei, was das alles ist und Informationen und alles. Und dann war ich an der Kasse und habe so ein paar Sachen gekauft. Und die Kassiererin hat dann in ihrem Buch geguckt, weil sie nicht wusste, was das für Früchte sind. Und dann bestanden hinter mir wie immer irgendwie fünf Leute, die irgendwie nervös waren und vorbeibolten. Und die haben gesagt, ja, was ist denn das für eine Frucht? Und ich so, ich habe keine Ahnung. Und wirklich alle... Aber du wusstest genau, was es war. Es ist eine Belode. Nee, nee, ich hatte es zu dem Zeitpunkt vergessen tatsächlich. Ich hatte es irgendwie einfach nur geguckt, so, ach, kenne ich nicht noch nie gesehen. Ist es eine Mirne? Genau, und es ist so lustig, weil fünf Leute hinter mir gucken mich an mit dem, ja, warum kaufst du es dann, Blick. Einfach so diese... Also, ich hatte kurz so eine Massendiskussion entstandenion entstanden. Was kann das sein? Und wurde so ein Professor gerufen, der genau bestimmen sollte, was das ist. Aber es ist so gut, wenn du was kaufst und die Leute fragen dich, ja, was ist das denn? Und du sagst, ich weiss es nicht. Wo tatsächlich die sehr berechtigte Frage in der Luft liegt, ja, warum gibst du dann Geld dafür aus? Und das war dann auch echt unangenehm. Und ich so, ja, ich weiss nicht, ihr wisst ja, was es kostet. Nee, und dann musste sie nochmal zurücklaufen und musste das Ding suchen und ich wusste halt auch nicht mehr, wo es war. Und ich stand da halt die ganze Zeit alleine an der Kasse und fünf Leute hinter mir mit diesem Du-Depp-Blick einfach, was soll das, das ist auch so gut, das kann man niemandem mehr klären, warum man etwas kauft, von dem man nicht weiss, was es ist. Ja, guck mal, zu deiner Frage eben, muss man rausgehen und was erleben? Ja, aber kann man da ein Stand-Up-Programm draus machen? Ja, klar. Nein, da kann man vielleicht einen Sticker machen, irgendwie einen Verkehrswimpel betrunken lassen mit der Story oder so, aber das ist nicht für Stand-Up geeignet. Ich glaube schon. Das kannst du auf dem Bleistift. Ich habe mich eben herrlich organisiert im Kopf, also ich glaube schon, dass es lustig ist.
Das war die Podcast-Ufou-Anekdote.
Erinnerst du dich vor zwei Folgen, da habe ich Ukulele gespielt?
Ukulele, Ukulele.
Und da ist mir was bewusst geworden.
So habe ich dann vom Ufou gespielt, sehr laut noch und danach auch.
Und habe mir dann vorgestellt, wie Nachbarn bei mir klingeln und sich darüber beschweren, dass ich laut Ukulele spiele. Ich hab mir das vorgestellt und ich war richtig sauer auf die Nachbarn. Es ist nie passiert, aber ich hasse meine Nachbarn, nur weil ich mir andauernd so Dinge vorstelle. Das war mir nicht, passiert dir das auch manchmal, dass du die Dinge vorstellst, die passieren könnten. Ja, und es ist dann so weit reinsteigert, dass es echt wird. Und dann auch so Dinge, dann war mein Elter mal zu Besuch bei mir in der Wohnung, dann war draußen, ging der Nachbar lang und dachte, ich hasse den, ich hasse den. Und meine Eltern haben gefragt, warum denn? Und wieso? Und ich wusste es nicht, ich hatte einfach keine Antwort drauf. Weil ich mir die ganze Zeit in meinem kranken Kopf, ich weiß nicht, liegt daran, dass man alleine wohnt, ich weiß es nicht. So ging der Holocaust los, so hat das angefangen. Ja, ohne Scheiss. Du bist raus hier! Warum? Ich habe Ukulele gespielt, und dann habe ich mir vorgestellt, dass er sich beschwert. Ja, okay, gut. Okay, aber weg mit dir. Das ist ein Grund. Und es geht sogar so weit, wo du das Einkaufen sagst, ich gehe auch immer einkaufen. No shit. Alter, jetzt kommen die Geheimnisse raus. Und dann steht vor meinem Rewe des Vertrauens, steht dann immer ein Bettler, der dann immer Geld will. Und ich gebe dem nie was, aber ich stelle mir sehr oft vor, dass ich ihm etwas gebe und er sich dann befreut. Und ich bin stolz darauf. Ich bin so ein riesen Arschloch einfach. Und dann denke ich mir auch so, nur weil man etwas nicht erreicht hat, es ist doch kein Grund, sich darauf nicht stolz zu sein. Absolut, und tatsächlich, ich glaube, das ist auch der Vorteil von großer Vorstellungskraft, dass du einfach deine Realität ändern kannst. Also was ich auch ganz gerne mache, ist so Tagträumen. Du hast dich dünn gedacht. Aber das, wenn ich irgendwie zum Supermarkt gehe oder so, das einzige Beispiel, das wir haben, was wir so machen. Wir sitzen rum, wir stehen auf, sitzen rum und gehen jedes Mal einkaufen. Wir denken, fuck, wir haben jetzt vier Beispiele, was man so macht, weil ich jedes Mal einkaufen gehe. Und da mache ich immer so Tagträume. Meine Tagträume sind immer, was würde ich machen, wenn ich drei Wünsche zur Verfügung hätte, was würde ich machen, wenn ich einen Lotto gewinnen würde. Was ist die Superkraft, die du wählen könntest? Ja, genau. Wenn ich fliegen könnte, mache ich immer. Was würde ich dann machen, wenn ich fliegen könnte? Und zum Beispiel, was ich im Lotto gewinnen würde, was ich mir dann alles kaufen würde und so, wie ich das Geld anlegen würde und alles und dass ich dann auch manchmal zum Supermarkt gehe, irgendwie einen anderen Supermarkt mal besuche, weil ich mehr einkaufen kann. Und irgendwann
gucke ich so und dann irgendwann denke ich mir
das Komlett durch und denke mir alles im kleinsten
Detail aus und dann kaufe ich gerade ein und dann
sehe ich irgendwie, will ich irgendwas kaufen
und dann denke ich mir, oh, das war recht teuer und dann denke ich mir,
ah ne, ich habe ja im Lotto gewonnen, das passt schon.
Und dann für einen kurzen Moment so,
hast du gerade
wirklich dir selber eingeredet,
dass du wirklich im Lotto
gewonnen hast? Also,
wie bescheuert bist du denn?
Vielen Dank. Hast du gerade wirklich dir selber eingeredet, dass du wirklich im Lotto geworden hast? Also wie bescheuert bist du denn? Aber das ist glaube ich das, dem wir verfallen sind. Wir leben sehr in unseren Gedanken. Das ist glaube ich auch was, was Stand-Up-Comedians generell erhofft haben. Wir denken einfach sehr oft über Dinge nach. Und ich bin auch so ein Grübler. Und ich grübel sehr oft Dinge. Und irgendwann denke ich mir auch, ist das jetzt passiert, damals, bist du wirklich, hast du wirklich die Berliner Mauer zum Einschluss gebracht oder hast du das vielleicht noch ausgedacht? Ja, da vor allem auch so, dass wir uns ja so intensiv mit irgendwelchen Medien beschäftigen, dass man auch manchmal nicht mehr weiß, ob einem Dinge selber passiert sind oder ob man sie in einem Film gesehen hat. Oder in einer Family Guy-Folge. Damals, als unser Hund Auto überfahren wurde, und dann haben wir uns einen neuen Hund gekauft und er wurde am ersten Tag direkt wieder vom Auto überfahren. Nope, nehme ich zurück. Das war eine Folge Simpsons. Aber auch so Dinge... Und was machst du so beruflich? Was hast du meine Annoten erzählen? Aber auch so Dinge, die nicht wirklich passieren können, sondern die nur in Animationsserien passieren können. Dann kam ein grosses gelbes Hühnchen, mit dem ich dann gekämpft habe. Ja, oder auch so Zeitsprünge. Und drei Wochen später dann... Ah ne, das klappt nicht, funktioniert nicht. Aber ich glaube, der Kreativität liegt ja generell eine Neugier zugrunde. Kreativität beginnt ja immer mit, was wäre wenn... Sehr gut. Ein Mann in seiner... Das muss man mal auf RTL eine Show nennen vielleicht. Genau,. Was wäre wenn ein Mann in seiner Midlife-Crisis plötzlich Crystal Meth kocht und ins Drogenbusiness einsteigt? Du verbindest zwei Dinge, die nicht zusammenpassen und lehnst dich dann zurück und guckst einfach, was passiert. Das ist im Grunde Kreativität. Und das ist ja auch irgendwie, wo Humor herkommt. Und die Schaffenskraft ist eine Neugier. Wie sind die Dinge aufgebaut? Oder wie wären Dinge, wenn sie übertriebener wären? Das sind die einfachste Frage. Genau, wenn man einfach Dinge wechselt, wenn man einfach sagt, okay, Dinge, die wir von einer Situation kennen, übertragen wir auf was anderes. Genau. Oder auch so ein Auge fürs Detail. Ich habe mir zum Beispiel letztens eine Dokumentation über Haie gesehen. Und da ist der Hai immer wieder so aus dem Wasser rausgesprungen und hat nach der Kamera geschnappt oder so. und da habe ich gesehen, dass der Hai ja ein riesiges Maul hat, jetzt nicht nur von den Zähnen her, sondern auch ein riesiges Erkenntnisse, mit Flur in die Bildung, Achtung, der Hai hat ein grosses Maul. Es gibt noch Karten für meine Tournee, Leute, noch sind sie nicht ausverkauftauft. Vor allem nicht nur von den Zähnen her, sondern auch vom Volumen des Mundraums.
Und dann dachte ich mir, wenn so ein Hai im Wasser durch die Gegend schwimmt, hat der ja Wasser im Mund.
Oder?
Der hat ja... Noch schlimmer, er hat Salzwasser im Mund.
Aber er hat ja in seinem Mund keine Luft.
Und ich dachte mir, wenn ich mir so einen Fisch vorstelle, der hat halt wie ein Mensch, der schwimmt durch die Gegend, aber der schwimmt ja sein ganzes Leben und hat Wasser im Mund. Das ist ja total verrückt. Da bin ich noch nie drauf gekommen. Für mich verändert das alles in der Welt der Fische, weil ich denke mich sehr oft in Fische hinein. Und du musst dir dir vorstellen, dass die konstant Wasser im Mund haben, immer. Weil die haben so oft, wie wir Wasser im Mund haben, haben die einfach Luft im Mund und ansonsten immer Wasser. Und die haben auch immer Wasser vor den Augen. Ja, und in den Ohren und ständig. Ihr hattest so oft vor dem Schwimmunterricht. Und das Schlimmste fand ich, dass man halt immer so immer Chlor in den Augen hat. Und die haben halt immer, die haben nie Chlor in den Augen. Die haben nie. Ja, aber die Frage ist, wo ist jetzt der Witz, fragt ihr euch, liebe Zuschauer, und da kann ich euch auch nicht weiterhelfen.
Ja, was sind diese Details? Ich bin eben hierher gefahren mit der U-Bahn und dann hat, jedes Mal begegnete ich diesem einen Mann, der, auch so einen Penner, glaube ich, der halt einfach, sagen wir mal, Obdachloser. Du hast eigentlich das beste soziale Umfeld.
Ein Obdachloser, der immer seine Obdachlosenzeitung verkaufen will.
Und wir kennen ihn schon, und er weiss schon, wie immer, ich will es wie immer, nicht. Stell ihm aber vor, dass ich ein guter Mensch bin, dem erhelfe. Und dann plötzlich hat ein, wie es in Köln so ist, die Leute werden ihn angesprochen. Und jemand hat ihn angesprochen und plötzlich war die ganze U-Bahn, alle haben vorher diese Zeitung abgelehnt, aber plötzlich war die ganze U-Bahn still und wollte wissen, was er zu sagen hatte. Plötzlich war die ganze U-Bahn still und hat dem Mann zugehört, der den Obdachlosen angesprochen hat. Und ich bin auch gefragt, ich fand das lustig in dem Moment, weil... Du hast laut gelacht, ja. Ich sass da, genau, dass auch Dinge positiv sehen. Ich habe die Zeitung nicht nur nicht gekauft. Ich hätte ja auch etwas viel Schlimmeres machen können, hier zu sagen, nein, die Zeitung will ich nicht. Hätte ich auch so reagieren können. Ich hätte es auch viel schlimmer machen können. Also, die einfach nur abzulehnen höflich, ist ja noch wirklich was Freundliches eigentlich. Aber das fand ich auch so lustig, dass es anscheinend ein unfassbarer Markt dafür ist, Gespräche mit Obdachlosen zu führen. So ein Tipp für euch da draußen, macht einfach mal einen Podcast mit den Obdachlosen. Das habe ich mir überlegt, als Setting für eine Serie, dass man eine Serie in der Welt der Obdachlosen macht. Ist, glaube ich, ganz geil, weil da gibt es natürlich auch wahnsinnig viel Kriminalität und so und halt so ähnlich wie Breaking Bad. Ja, aber die sind nicht gebildet und dann sind die Gespräche so ganz komisch und so langweilig. Und auch polnisch hauptsächlich, man versteht kein Wort. Weil die sich nicht ausdrücken können. Das ist natürlich schlecht. Ja, man kann ja vielleicht so ein Tanzkärter Pantomie mit rausmachen. Das ist vielleicht was anderes. Oder zum Beispiel, ich dachte mir, die Vorstellung davon, dass die Alliierten Berlin einnehmen im Zweiten Weltkrieg und dann irgendwie die ganzen Nazis festnehmen und dann zwei Soldaten halt irgendwie in so einen Raum reinbrechen und dann sind halt die ganzen Sekretärinnen und denken, ja, Sekretärin verhaften wir jetzt auch, weil es sind ja auch Nazis irgendwie und dann okay, die Diener, die ihnen jetzt Wasser gebracht haben, sind ja auch irgendwo Nazis, machen die nächst. Was ist das für eine Vorstellung? Man muss sich halt überlegen, wer ist jetzt wirklich verantwortlich hier? Die Soldaten sind per se verantwortlich, Offiziere, Hitler, Politiker, alle verantwortlich. Aber wie weit geht man? Und dann, okay, ja gut, die Kinder sollen wir die auch verhaften und dann nächste Tür geht auf und da ist Hitlers Hund. Und sie überlegen sich, naja, rein theoretisch hätte er den Holocaust verhindern können. Also eigentlich, also die sich zu überlegen, so wäre Hitler allergisch gegen Hundehaare, der das kann sich jetzt ganz anders aus. Ja, aber die zwei verunruhigte Soldaten, die sich überlegen, sollen wir den Hund auch verhaften? Wie weit geht das hier? Wir haben gesagt, alle Nazis verhaften. Sollen wir den Hund verhaften und dann irgendwie Tag drei vor Gericht, der Hund, die internationalen Berichterstatter sind außer sich, der Hund hat noch nicht mal die Uniform abgenommen, er ist tatsächlich Nazi. Er hat immer noch dieses Hakenkreuz-Brandzeichen in seinem Fell. Er hätte auch mal ablegen können vielleicht. Ja, jetzt dachte ich irgendwie, man kann ein Wortschirm machen, irgendwie tausendjähriges Fell oder sowas, aber ich habe es zum Glück nicht gesagt. Nein.
Du kannst es nicht dann so doch sagen.
Das geht nicht.
Du hast gerade so ein Grossmembran-Mikrofon.
Ohne Ständer, also nur
mit dem Stab in der Hand.
Du laufst so Freddie Mercury-mäßig die ganze Zeit hier durch den Raum.
Was mich ein bisschen verunsichert
und mich ein bisschen nervös macht.
So ein bisschen wie eine Selfie-Stange, nur mit einem Mikrofon. Und andersrum. Wir schicken euch ein Bild oder nicht oder schneiden den Fall vollständig raus. Schneiden die ganzen 20 Minuten raus. Mir ist aufgefallen, der Mensch ist ja an der Spitze der Evolution. Das ist mir aufgefallen. So, kommen wir zu unserer nächsten Rubrik. Das ist mir danach aufgefallen. 50 Funfacts mit Stefan Teitzel. Das ist mir aufgefallen, nachdem mir aufgefallen ist, dass Fische ja immer Wasser im Mund haben. Und zwar gab es dann... Ich glaube, viele Menschen waren nicht bewusst, dass Fische konstant Wasser im Mund haben. Schreibt es in die Kommentare. Selbst einige Fische haben erstaunt, die zufolge gehört. Ja, haben ausserliche Wasser runtergeschuckt, so Wuss! Haben sie sich was schluckt? Können Fische sich eigentlich was schlucken? Das sind wieder die fünf Minuten, die wir euch Zeit lassen, um darüber nachzudenken. Zu googeln, ja, die Google-Pause. Sollen wir mal einführen vielleicht, eine Google-Pause? Ja. Also eine Klo-Pause, wo man soäckebrot ess-Pause. Genau. Ich stelle mir immer die Zuschauerinnen so vor, wie sie zu Hause ist mit dem Knäckebrot in der Hand und immer so ich kann nicht mehr, ich muss dieses Knäcke, der nächste Gag ist bestimmt nicht so gut, okay, jetzt redet Stefan wieder, jetzt habe ich vielleicht eine Chance und nein! Und sie lachen, oh nein, ist weg! Mir ist aufgefallen, dass die Menschen an der Spitze der Revolution sind, als ich ein Video gesehen habe von einer Schildkröte, der eine GoPro aufgesetzt wurde. Wie sie durchs Wasser geschwommen ist. Wo ich mir denke, was glauben Menschen, was sie da sehen? Das ist einfach, sie sehen wahrscheinlich das, was sie bei den anderen zwölf Tieren gesehen haben, die auch mal eine GoPro auf dem Rücken genäht haben. Und erst mal frage ich mich, nehmen die Menschen das doch wieder weg oder schwimmen die ihr Leben lang mit der GoPro da rum? Gute Frage. Und wie reagieren andere Schildkröten auf die? Und dann würde ich gleich den Satz, hast du abgenommen, Gerry? Irgendwie sieht es so anders aus, irgendwas. Meine Frisur? Irgendwie sieht es so anders aus, irgendwie so. Nee, weiss nicht, irgendwie. Ich dachte gerade, du fragst, will ich mich, ob ich abgenommen habe. Aber kurz, das sind auch so Dinge, durch alleine Schieße. Acting, the art of acting in theater, to turn reality into an illusion. That is my craft. Florentin hat an dieser Stelle noch fünf, zehn Minuten. Jetzt sind alle wieder wach. Ich weiß nicht, was es ist. Alle, die jetzt das Podcast-Ufe zum Einschlafen verwenden, was eigentlich Schwachsinn ist, sind jetzt aufgewachsen. Ja, mach weiter. Aber allein der Gedanke daran, dass du gerade gesagt hast, dass ich gedacht habe, dass du mich meinst, dass ich abgenommen habe, hat mich schon wieder froh gestimmt. Ja, genau. Und jetzt gleich, wenn wir essen gehen, denkst du dir, ich kann doch was essen, ich habe abgenommen. Das ist vollkommene Leichtgleichigkeit. Was der Grund ist, warum wir kontinuierlich unser Leben versenken einfach. Ja, weil wir auch denken, selbst wenn es uns scheisse geht, wir denken uns die Welt, wie wir sie wollen. Also das ist ja auch so, dass man damit eigentlich vollständig immun ist. Leute, die immer sagen, das Glas ist halb voll, werden wahrscheinlich an Dehydration sterben. Kann ich mir ganz gut vorstellen.
Das sind so Sätze, die einfach klug klingen, aber nicht klug klingen.
Naja, komm. Die trinken zu wenig?
Ist vielleicht ein Tüterin, weiß ich nicht.
Ach so, die immer denken, es sei mehr drin, als es ist.
Ja, muss man anders formulieren.
Schreibt es auf ein T-Shirt und schickt es uns.
Machen wir heute Abend.
Nee, aber ich würde gerne den Satz so formulieren, dass die Lebewesen an der Spitze der Evolution stehen, die anderen Tieren eine GoPro auszubilden. Das ist auch, glaube ich, die Definition von Herrenrasse, sobald du eine GoPro auf die andere schnalzt, hast du es geschafft. Ich glaube, Darwin hätte uns selbst gelobt. Ja, Darwin hätte gesagt, nice, David ist unser Kumpel. Ja, aber tatsächlich, es ist sehr beruhigend, sich diese Schildkröte anzuschauen.
Wie lange geht denn die Folge eigentlich?
Sag mal, fünf Minuten, was ist denn hier los?
Ich fand es tatsächlich sehr entspannt, diese Schildkröte zuzuschauen.
Ich hatte aber echt ein schlechtes Gewissen wegen Datenschutz ein bisschen, weil ich mir dachte,
was, wenn die sich jetzt eine Folge Friends anguckt? Was war das? Tatsächlich ein Problem, ja. Oh scheiße, sie hat Nirvana. Fuck, Leute, wir haben die Rechte nicht. Nimm den Stream runter. Nicht schlecht, nicht schlecht. Es ist extrem schwierig, das in Stand-Up einzubauen, weil man acht Minuten lang davor trocken erklären muss, was jetzt gerade das war. Da habe ich auch Angst vor. Also 46 Minuten musst du da hinleiten. Und dann ein Okay. Deswegen trage ein lustiges T-Shirt, damit die Leute in den ersten 30 Sekunden schon mal nur über das T-Shirt lachen, während du schon mal anfängst, den ersten Gag aufzubauen. Ich glaube, das funktioniert schon ganz gut. Nicht schlecht, nicht schlecht, hat mir gut gefallen. Ja doch, wird doch. Es wird langsam. Das ist unsere 30. Folge, oder? 29. Folge tatsächlich, glaube ich, oder? Nee, 30. Ihr wisst jetzt schon mehr als wir, wir gucken kurz noch mal fünf Minuten nach, um es ein bisschen spannender zu machen.
Ich finde auch so Podcasts gut, die immer auch beim zehnten Mal, wenn sie es machen, immer noch Spannung aufbauen, was das Thema der Sendung ist, wenn das Thema der Sendung immer im Titel des Podcasts steht. Ja, da sind selbstsüchtige Menschen. Worüber reden wir heute? Wir geben euch mal einen Tipp. Es hat was mit Science Fiction zu tun.
Aber es ist ja Star Wars Teil drei von fünf. Und es hat auch ein bisschen was mit Licht zu tun. Es ist ein Star Wars Podcast.
Im Hintergrund läuft die New Hope Soundtrack. Wovon redet ihr? Was ist hier los?
Einfach zwanzig Minuten lang einfach, oh, ja, es kommt auch ein
grosser Bär drin vor.
Ja, aber das ist
eine fehlende Empathie.
Die haben wir aber auch.
Wir haben bei Oli P. auch zehn Minuten
darüber geredet, jetzt kommt die Tür rein.
Wer kommt denn da rein und erfolgt einfach
Oli P. und in zehn Ankündigungstexten
stand Oli fucking P. ist zu Gast.
Ja, ja, ja. Aber man denkt da nicht dran. Man denkt nicht weit genug. Das ist schon okay. Leute. Ich glaube, es tut den Podcast gut, wenn wir in einem Raum sind. Ich finde, das merkt man heute. Ich habe zum ersten Mal mit Spaß dabei. Aber willst du berühmt werden? Hast du Angst vor dem Ruhm oder bist du da gewappnet? Ich glaube, dass Leute, die berühmt werden wollen, Angst vor dem Ruhm haben. Wenn du, also als angenommen... Der Frage entschickt, geschickt entgehen. Du träumst ja wahrscheinlich auch mal, du fantasierst ja in den Tagträumen auch manchmal, dass du eine Frau kennenlernst. Irgendwo. Ich finde es immer noch sehr unrealistisch. Extrem unrealistisch. Ich kann mir Frauen nicht vorstellen. Ja, ich denke mir, nicht geh zurück zur Science-Fiction-Version, die scheitert die Zeit ein. Manchmal haben die Frauen auch Fell. Sitzt du in dem X-W Das ist nicht das richtige Getriebe. Sagt man X-Wing? Ich vertraue dir ja dann immer, weil du so englisch ein bisschen versierter bist. Sagt man X-Wing? Ich würde sagen, bei Wing würde man dann schon. Also wenn dann X-Flügler kann man sagen oder X-Wing. Aber X-Wing ist dann schon ein bisschen komisch. Und ich frage dich mal, willst du, also wir haben jetzt das Podcast-Ufo. Und angenommen, du lernst eine auf einer Party kennen, würdest du wollen, dass sich schon das Podcast-Ufo gehört hat oder nicht? Nee, also allein, ich finde, das hat er auch mal, ich weiss nicht, wer es gesagt hat,
aber irgendwer hat mal gesagt, dass man vor Kritik kann man sich ja schützen, vor Lob ist man machtlos.
Und das stimmt er auch mal, ich weiß nicht, wer es gesagt hat, aber irgendwer hat mal gesagt, dass man vor Kritik kann man sich ja schützen, vor Lob ist man machtlos. Und das stimmt ja auch. Das ist wie ein Butterkäse auf meiner Zunge. Flo hat gerade sein Shirt ausgezogen. Aufgegessen. Ist wie Butter auf der Zunge, ein bisschen Hunger bekommen hat. Ich finde aber, nee, ich finde das nicht gut. Es ist ja auch bei dir so, wenn du einen Fan triffst. Einer deiner vielen Fans trifft. Ja, aber auf der anderen Seite denkt man sich, du kommst ja ganz gut rüber im Podcast. Hier ist so mehr oder weniger eine Comfortzone. Die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass du hier... Das ist das Gegenteil einer Comfortzone. Man ist eine Stunde lang beschussend und muss abnehmen. Extrem heiß. Na ja, gut, aber ich sag mal, du bist wahrscheinlich hier irgendwie entspannter und lockerer, als wenn du direkt vor der Frau stehst und mit ihr reden und performen musst. Und deswegen denke ich mir, okay, die weiss, dass ich was drauf habe. Nee, ich will dich rumbekommen und deswegen habe ich immer mal einen Vorwand, einen Podcast mit dir zu machen. Der Langzeitplan, ja. Jetzt zum Beispiel, gestern ist mir etwas total Unangenehmes passiert und zwar ist es ein... Du stellst immer Fragen, um dann zu deinem Thema hinzuleiten, ne? Das ist ganz interessant. Ich will wissen, wie du es siehst. Ich will nicht erst meine Meinung sagen und dann deine Meinung fragen, sondern erst mal, wie du es machst. Weil es ist echt unangenehm, weil ich freue mich immer, wenn Leute wissen, was ich mache und mich schon so ein bisschen kennen, weil ich habe immer das Gefühl, ich kann mich sehr schlecht verkaufen. Und du erlebst ja nicht viel anderes, also du wirst ja eh so dem Thema kommen. Ja, absolut. Und dann ist es aber auch cooler, wenn jemand anderes sagt, oh, du bist ja berühmt und bist im Fernsehen, erzähl mal was davon. Absolut. Als wenn du selber anfängst zu erzählen, übrigens, ich bin Star. Und es ist immer so gut, weil ich mag es immer, wenn man irgendeine Möglichkeit findet, diese Smalltalk-Barriere zu durchbrechen und gleich über interessante Themen zu sprechen. Zum Beispiel auf Tinder mache ich schon in meinem Beschreibungstext Gags, damit ich schon mal die Leute aussortiere, die keinen Humor haben. Da steht dann irgendwie zum Beispiel dreieinhalb Zentimeter pure Lust oder sowas da, wo ich mir denke, ich glaube, es wird immer weniger, glaube ich. Deswegen, Ladies, ich muss mich ein bisschen beeilen. Das ist wirklich einfacher. Und deswegen, um dich schon mal auszudänen. Aber zum Beispiel ist gestern eine sehr attraktive... Es wird immer ein bisschen lustiger, dass du immer ein bisschen mehr Frauen aussortierst. Ja, genau. Nee, ich habe nur... Nee, wie könnte man denn... Ich habe nur einen kleinen Penis, um meinen Porsche zu kompensieren. Ah ja, gut. Ist okay. Könnt ihr haben. Könnt ihr so haben. Gebe ich euch. Nicht schmeißen Gag raus und sonst. Nämlich hat tatsächlich eine relativ attraktive Frau angesprochen und hat gesagt, hey, ich finde deine Tweets total gut. Wollte ich nur sagen. Ciao. So. Und dann war ich in der Situation, ich wollte mich eigentlich mit ihr unterhalten und sie kennenlernen. Ich kann jetzt aber nicht mehr mit ihr sprechen, weil das total erbärmlich wirken würde, wenn sie mir gerade gesagt hat, so ein bisschen, er vorzuhören, so, hey, ich finde das total geil, was du machst, ich will dich gar nicht länger stören, und dann sagst du, nee, ich will doch mit dir reden, bitte, ich will mehr von deiner Anerkennung, bitte, und es ist echt eine Situation, wo jeder andere hätte mal mit der Person reden können und ich nicht, also, damit es nicht falsch rüberkommt, sowas passiert extrem selten, sowas passiert vielleicht alle zwei
Monate mal. Das ist nicht so, als würde es ständig passieren.
Ich will nicht, dass ihr mich so als unantastbaren
Typen kennt. Ich bin ein Typ zum
Anfassen, das wisst ihr, das kennt ihr mich.
Die meisten Zuhörer kennen
mich ja, sind mit mir verwandt, deswegen ist das ja alles in Ordnung.
Leute, ist euch
schon mal aufgefallen, dass, wenn ihr
euch übergebt... Das ist der Moment, wo er sein Gags-Dokument aufgemacht hat. Warte mal, ich habe jetzt auch ein Gags-Dokument. Wollen wir mal kurz ein Gag-Battle raushauen? Nee, ich will die alle noch als Tweets raushauen. Du machst es auch ähnlich. Und die sind auch alle nicht gut. Du haust die eh nicht als Tweets raus. Ja, nee, ich nehme mir mal vor, du haust jetzt mehr Gags raus, dann ist es egal, wenn einer mal scheiße ist, weil du hast ja sehr viele raus und dann ist eher so dieses Quantitätsding und wenn da mal ein paar gut dabei sind und vielleicht triffst du auch, du streust quasi so Schrotflittenmechanik, du triffst halt irgendwann mal irgendein bestes Humorzentrum, aber das mache ich dann meistens nicht, meistens denke ich dann doch, du haust nur gute Gags auf, unter denen es fehlt. Es ist halt auch wieder die Frage zwischen Fabriktheorie gegen Katzentheorie, dass also wird man lustiger...
Fabriktheorie gegen Lichtschalter. Wird man lustiger, je mehr Gags man hat, oder hat man ein limitiertes Gag-Quantum? Sodass wir vor der Sendung sagen, mach jetzt keine Gags, sonst hast du einen Podcast weniger. Oder je mehr Gags du letztendlich machst, desto besser wird deine Fabrik, weil mehr Gags deine Fabrik durchwandern, desto besser werden die Gags danach. Ist da noch was anderes, ich sehe es ja eher so wie so eine Bewerbung, so ein Curriculum, so ein Showreel, gagtechnisch, wo man einfach die besten Sachen drin haben will und so ein Gespräch ist ja natürlich lustiger, je mehr Gags man raushaut. Da ist auch die Chance dabei, dass man lustig ist, dass man größer. An Spielern und an Scheitern lernst du natürlich auch und auch wenn du schlechte Gags raushushaust. Unsauer macht lustig. Ich meine, bei dir ist es mittlerweile so, dass du vor Angst schlechte Gags machst, gar keine Mammel machst, auch später. Oder halt kaum noch was. Und wo ich mir wirklich Sorgen mache und mir denke, ist das wirklich nicht die falsche Range in zwei. Ich hätte mir auch noch nicht Sorgen gemacht um dich, weil du einfach plötzlich so zehn Minuten hattest, wo du Milliarden Tweets rausgehauen hast, wo die Kamera immer folgen konnte. Und mir auch dachte, was ist jetzt Endzeitstimmung, will ich nachher umbringen oder so, was ist jetzt los? Meine Legende noch zu Ende führen. Ich habe tatsächlich Tweets nach meinem Tod gescheduled. Wenn ich jetzt sterbe, auf Twitter ziehe ich weiter. Das ist ja eine grössere Idee. Ja, ich habe Tweets, ich glaube, in 50 und in 100 Jahren habe ich Tweets gescheduled. Ist einfrieren für dich so ein Ding? Nein. So ein Dingpunkt, wo man sehr schnell sagen kann, nein, ohne zu überlegen. Man kann direkt nein sagen, ist einfach so ein Ding. Nee, Einfrieren habe ich nicht vor. Ich war zwar nicht überlegt. Warum ist Einfrieren bei dir so ein Ding zu fragen, als wäre das wirklich so eine Diskussion, die man stellt, die man voraussetzt. Aber bei mir ist es glaube ich, ich werde mich glaube ich einfrieren lassen, so im Alter von 80 oder so. Und dann halt soll ich mich auffrieren, auftauen, wenn ich halt irgendwie, wenn man die Technik dafür hat und so, das machen kann. Das ist doch geil, dann kannst du in der Zukunft gucken, wie es da aussieht und so. Glaubst du, es ist unangenehm für Annette Frier, wenn sie sich einfrieren lassen will, dass es ein unangenehmes Gespräch ist? Guten Tag. In der Zukunft. Ich habe mich dazu geschlossen, ich will mich einfrieren lassen. Ja, Frau Frier. Ach, wegen dem Namen jetzt. Du, die letzten zehn Minuten des Podcasts sind immer ein bisschen schwierig, das weisst du. Was? Ich dachte, wir wären jetzt locker schon drüber. Nee. Das sind immer die... Es geht weiter. Man würde in anderen Situationen was sagen. Wie, was, noch zehn Minuten? Zehn Minuten muss ich noch mit dir reden? Och, was soll das denn irgendwie? Ja, aber sobald man eine Zeit im Hinterkopf hat, so die Uhr ticken hört, ist das auch unangenehm. Also wenn man mit einer Frau nach dem Date an einer U-Bahn-Station steht und beide wollen nach Hause oder so, und man sieht die Zeit, wie in Köln steht dann immer, in zehn Minuten kommt die nächste Bahn. Man hat jetzt noch zehn Minuten und man teilt sich die Gags, die man sich noch aufgeschrieben hat, irgendwie ein, die zehn Minuten lang. Die drei, die ganz unten zwischen den Krümeln im Humorbeutel, zwischen den Krümeln und den Flocken noch ein paar rumliegen und du reisst tief und irgendwas ist da noch, irgendwas habe ich noch. Aber wie verteilt man die jetzt oder wie bereitet man die Themen vor? Und das Schlimmste ist, wenn du dir gute Gags vorbereitet hast und die Gags gehen unter. Irgendwie du machst einen Gag und sie hustet gerade oder kriegt gerade einen Orgasmus oder irgendwie sowas. Das habe ich bei dir auch immer. Wenn ich diese Gags vorbereite, bin ich mir gedacht, okay, den musst du dir auch bewahren. In dem Moment kackt Skype einfach ab oder so. Genau. Sagt man es dann nochmal oder nicht und das ist dann echt schwierig. Manchmal will ich auch nachfragen, hast du den Gag gerade gehört oder soll ich den nochmal machen? So unangenehm. Ja, man muss halt haushalten. Man muss halt echt haushalten. Was machen normale Leute eigentlich, wenn die mit Frauen reden, anstatt ständig Gagse?? Was machen normale Leute eigentlich den ganzen Tag außer Einkaufen gehen? Das kann ich ja noch nachvollziehen. Echt eine gute Frage. Aber alles andere geht mir völlig ab. Das ist wirklich eine gute Frage. Aber es stimmt tatsächlich, dass Zeiten, wenn man weiss, wie viel Zeit auf dem Spiel steht, sie werden sich unangenehmer, als wenn man einfach unbestimmte Zeit auf ein Taxi warten muss oder so. Ja, das hat man an der Schule auch schon gemerkt. Oder dass man zehn Minuten warten muss. Das ist echt unangenehm. Ja, aber sobald eine Uhr im Klassenzimmer war, man sieht, man hat noch zehn Minuten, guckt man halt ständig auf die Uhr und hat die Zeit halt, wenn man sich bewusst macht die Zeit, wird sie ja irgendwie weird und man muss halt darauf achten. Aber wenn die Zeit einfach nur nebenbei läuft, dann vergeht man schnell. Zeit vergeht schneller, je weiter weg Uhren sind. Dankeschön. Das war wieder die philosophische Sternstunde. Das nächste T-Shirt bestellbar auf merchandise.podcast-ufo. Aber ich habe tatsächlich mir als Schüler wahnsinnig kreative Ideen überlegt, wie man Uhren anschauen kann. Einfach wie sich dann Uhren irgendwie dann... Man kann sie seitlich anschauen, man kann Uhren abnehmen und von oben drauf schauen. Ja, aber machst du das nicht so, dass du die Zeiteinheiten, die du überbrücken willst, einteilst?
Dass du dir, wenn du irgendwie ein Wochenende auf so einem Seminar oder Lehrgang bist,
dass du dir dann genau so eine Einteilung machst und sagst... Ach, so einer, was du dir in Striche gemacht hast oder so.
Oder irgendwie so Abschnitte dann abgehakt hast oder so.
Okay, ich habe jetzt noch, ich habe jetzt 18 von 624 habe ich schon.
Okay, 19 von 826 habe ich schon.
Okay, es wird langsam so.
Das ist, glaube ich, da kann man dann der Zeit auch Herr werden eigentlich. Herr der Zeit. Herr der Ringe. Die letzten acht Minuten sind Assoziationsspiel. Das ist nicht recht. Das Podcast-Lufo-Assoziationsspiel. Booster. Du kannst auch einen Gag machen jetzt. Nee, das ist immer so, wenn man sowieso schon weiß, dass der Teil rausgeschnitten wird. Da kommt Licht aus der Fuge zum Nebenraum. Wie creepy ist das denn? Ja, so grüßlich. Das wird auch, glaube ich, hier auch nicht so gewissenhaft alles gebaut. Das muss ja sehr schnell entstehen hier alles. Wir sagen dem Zuhörer jetzt extra nicht, wo wir gerade sind. Komm, irgendwas Gutes machen wir noch. Stell dir mal vor, dass Standard ist so, einen guten Mai ist noch, dann soll man auch Feier haben, Leute. Ne, Leute, einen mache ich jetzt schon noch, das muss jetzt schon noch sein. Das ist auch eine Schreibtechnik für Standard zum Beispiel, dass man halt immer einen Rausgeher braucht und man fängt an... Du sollst die Bühne verlassen, meinst du?
Der letzte Teil ist immer der Rausgeher, man geht raus, man verlässt die Bühne.
Das ist schon wichtig, dass der auf jeden Fall mit stattfindet.
Möglichst schlechte Gags machen, damit die Leute gehen und diese Verabschiedung nicht so awkward wird.
Nee, ich dachte jetzt eher so einen typischen Rausgeher-Gag, also einen sehr guten Gag.
Closer.
Sehr gut, danke, dass du mich aus diesem...
dass du mich da rausholst, sprachlich. Ah, wie er den Schnitt vorbereitet hat, sehr gut. Meisterlich gelöst von Stefan Titzer an der Stelle, sehr, sehr schön. Und man schreibt einfach einen Gag und denkt sich, gut, der ist jetzt noch nicht so gut dafür, dass ich ihn dann als packen will. Und man hat dann quasi die Anforderung, ihn selber jetzt einen besseren Gag zu schreiben. Und man macht das so lange, versucht man diesen Closer zu finden, dass man immer sagt, gut, ich will noch einen besseren, noch einen besseren, ich brauche einen Closer noch, dass halt mehr entsteht. Und man baut sich so halt dann sein Programm zurecht und am Ende hat man fünf Stunden Material. Aber möchtest du denn in deinem Stand-up auch irgendeine politische Botschaft verbringen oder so eine Art Gesellschaftskritik einbauen oder irgendwas, eine Message haben? Ja, andere Menschen sind scheiße. Andere Menschen sollten... Ich glaube, das wissen viele Menschen. Andere Menschen sollten sich viel uncooler werden. Ich finde auch, ich will nicht besser werden. Ich bin so faul, ich habe so abgeschlossen mit meinem Leben, ich will nicht besser werden, anders sind einfach nur schlechter werden. Ich will den Durchschnitt senken. War nicht dein größter Wunsch, dass alle anderen Menschen dicker werden? In der ersten Folge. Das habe ich nur so gesagt, das ist ja nicht mehr wirklicher Wunsch. Das war nur meine Comedy-Person, da bin ich aus mir gesprochen. Ich war nicht ich selbst. Ich war besessen von meiner Comedy-Person, Stefan Teitzel. Damals hieß ja auch noch Tizioso. Tizioso, ja, richtig. Ja, es ist warm hier drin. Ja, vor allem dieser Raum verleitet auch dazu, dass man unfassbar gute erste Viertelstunde abballert und ein Konzern, ein schlichter Ried. Und ein harter Schnitt, genau. Ja. Naja, so gut war die auch nicht. Ja, vielen Dank fürs Zuhören mal wieder. Ich bedanke mich bei unserem Redaktionsteam, bei Louis C.K., meinem Vater.
Wir bedanken uns bei allen, von denen wir heute Gagsel klaut haben. Субтитры создавал DimaTorzok